drinking and driving can lead to
terrible consequences on many levels
including
legally that's the topic of today's law
vegas now segment with eric palacios who
i spoke with earlier today
i asked eric legally speaking what
constitutes a dui
a lot of people think that they have to
be driving
in order to get a dui but the
law states that you have to be driving
or be in control of a vehicle
so it's enough to be in the car with the
keys
the car doesn't have to be turned on the
keys don't have to be in the ignition
a lot of people try to uh say well i was
just sleeping it off i'm in the
passenger side i thought i didn't have
the car on
i wasn't going to drive but that's not
enough you can still be charged
with driving while under the influence
for being in the car
with the keys and that means you're in
control of the vehicle
even passenger seat backs doesn't it's
going to depend on the police
if they decide to uh press charges
or give you a citation for it but it can
be enough to be in the vehicle
with the keys even if the car isn't
turned on and even if you're in the
passenger seat or the backseat
of course this leaves room for us as
attorneys to argue on your behalf
but it's still a better idea to not
have the keys and be in the car of
course the most dire con
dui is loss of life or injuries that
could occur as a result of drunk driving
either to the driver or to others on the
road so that's
number one what are the legal
consequences that one might face
well there's a lot of them and they're
gonna care stay with you for years to
come
uh first of all you have obviously be
arrested and processed you can be
in jail from two days to six months
that's up to the judge
you will also have fines around a
thousand dollars you'll have to go to a
dui school and also a victim
impact panel that's where you see uh
people that have suffered through the
negligence and drunk driving of somebody
else and what they've had to go through
so that's also not not a pleasant uh
experience uh and on top of that it'll
be on your record
and your insurance rates will go up for
years to come well it's always important
to
seek the help of an attorney uh as an
attorney we try to
minimize the damage caused by uh dui
charges
and uh sometimes we can see if there's
been
mistakes made in the reporting and the
testing and the prosecution
and then we can try to get the charges
reduced uh or dismissed so it's always
important to
not handle it yourself let our
professional help you through this and
we'll get the best results possible
meantime use uber drive all the things
that's it exactly and we actually have
an ad campaign
uh that says it's better to call uber
tonight than an attorney in the morning
so
be smart after you've had a few drinks
play it safe and get a ride home
you can give eric palacios and
associates a call that phone number
702-444-7777